I wanted to follow up on mario's this
question because I'm also really
interested in how education can become a
vehicle for creating more long-term
structural change I was wondering if
your foundation partners with you know
civil organizations with a government to
create opportunities for students once
they've completed the education to
create infrastructure opportunities for
them to continue using and applying the
knowledge they've acquired during their
time at the school's like if if there is
a model for sustainable change in that
regard paired up with local gut
guatemalan organization right not
actively more we're more interested in
finding outside help but we actually the
new mayor we have formed a sort of can
convene you another word I can't think
of in English like a public-private
partnership something like this I
thought there's a partnership an
agreement I think he would call sorry
because the new mayor is I met in the
States he worked in the States for 10 10
years and he's young and they had this
whole energetic wonderful team that
really wants for the first time I've
ever seen Guatemalan local Guatemalan
governance where they really seem to
care about the future of the town I mean
it's such a stereotype cliche to say
that they're corrupt and whatever but
that's mostly what we've seen is that
the mayor's don't do much really but but
the new one is quite impressively was
just sworn in in january fifteenth and
so we do hope we hope that we can
actually help him with our students use
them to gather data for instance on
garbage water pollution and and whatever
we might do in terms of the fighting the
hydroelectric power company and mining
interests that want to come in to town
but we have tried to I'm kind of
interested in getting the kids outside
of Guatemala as much as possible because
I think that
that will give them those much broader
perspective and we have one we have
three kids studying medicine and Cuba
because there's not a single doctor
there's now one doctor that speaks their
language you know they don't speak
Spanish in the home they only speak
Spanish in school so he's he there in
Cuba and we have some in in Mexico
studying business administration than we
have an educator the guy studying
education in Guatemala City but I that I
think it still remains to be seen I
think an answer to your question we
would like to but there's this get the
school's only graduated five five
classes that's pretty new so because
it's pretty new have you developed and
that tricks to gauge long-term impact or
it are you focused more on the short
term for now I just don't I don't think
I know yet what happened what you mean
well the hard what will happen how what
will happen with these kids you know cuz
there when they leave they want to they
want it they think that mean for me
success is when if they come back that's
one one way of measuring success they
would come back and find ways of
generating money within the town or they
come back and our doctor they care for
their fellow or they build or their
engineers and they build sustainable
electric power whatever but so far we
can't know that and I think what happens
to the whole the whole migration flood
of migration to the states is new and
something like that it's only about 12
years old they haven't been coming here
very long and the economy in 12 years
has completely been taken over by
remittances and that and whatever the
American economy basically runs it so we
just don't know I mean they all leak
they come to the state thinking they're
going to build a house and go home but
it's too new a phenomenon and the school
is too new
Thank to make any measurements yet
that's what I bank would you are
graduating students we're graduating
students we have a hundred graduates and
that's 100 more than ten years ago I
don't think there was a single college
graduate and maybe it less than a dozen
high school graduate within this
community of 50,000 people but it's
changing but well I think it's hard to
know how to judge it I mean even with
all those good things there's that has a
downside I'm sure we haven't thought of